bienvenue la paix watts notre équipe
c'est l'élite de l'élite sommes l'âme de
cette plage témoin des faits qu un peu
plus gros dégage comme à poutres
apparentes ça marche une grande poutre
énorme
les petite sirène s'est bien passé les
sélections pas besoin chez matt brody
j'étais médaille d'or mavrodi matt brody
bien sûr sauf que nous on s'emballe et
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu mates mais
son jeune femme ici ici pour intégrer
cette équipe pointe direction faut le
mériter
rien à voir avec celle du transport de
frigo ont quitté une bête king kong
mais moi je rapide drogue meurtre un
cadavre sur notre plage tout a commencé
quand elle est un oubli j'ai bien
repérer votre petit jeune on va devoir
faire ce que des watts 7h02 vous êtes
maître nageur pas policier
[Musique]
pourquoi on a toujours l'impression
qu'elle courant ralentissent cette fille
est la preuve que dieu existe
faut y aller incognito ou est-ce qu'il
est passé brody
pourquoi tu t'es maquiller comment ça
pourquoi je suis maquillée c'est un peu
chargé je suis canon super bonne 13
je suis un tsunami risque
c'est un bon ami peut aller se rhabiller
de rentrer en france
pourquoi on est venu à la mort pour
chercher des braves j'écoutais qui vient
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors fausse cacher
tout ça je suis couché sur une vieille
dame morte pourquoi tout près ce tiroir
nous ils sont vides
y a un truc cool dessus c'est juste du
grap cadavre de la grèce produite par la
nécrose 7h après c'est bon là je me
casse
[Musique]